ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]
tous ensemble déterminé à ne rien lâcher
le csc extraordinaire de ce matin auquel
ont assisté les délégués syndicaux de la
cgt a laissé de nombreuses questions en
suspens quant à l'avenir de la papeterie
l'offre de reprise qui a été acceptée
par l'upm le groupe finlandais
propriétaire du site
aucun ici ne la comprend elle prévoit un
démantèlement du site qui est unique en
france pour à la place ya installé une
unité de production d'hydrogène pour les
syndicats impossible de laisser passer
ça d'autant que grâce à leur
mobilisation
une offre pape etienne est sur la table
mais pour qu'elle aboutisse
ils ont besoin de temps on a demandé à
l'état à bercy au ministère de
l'industrie les autres de jouer leur
rôle de prendre publiquement une
position sans chapelle darblay de
facilité de prendre position oui et de
faciliter une industrie papetière
redémarrage industriel pas petit sur
chapelle darblay notre accord est tombé
le 30 juin 2021 pardon les positions
prises par l'état c'est à vous de jouer
les salariés et syndicats ont réussi à
mobiliser de nombreux acteurs dans leur
lutte
philippe martinez secrétaire général de
la cgt la mère de grand-couronne
plusieurs ong comme greenpeace ou encore
le président du ceser le conseil
économique social et environnemental
régional
pour ce dernier le projet hydrogène n'a
rien à faire sur ce site
le ceser après position en faveur
suite à une sollicitation d'ailleurs des
représentants du personnel de chapelle
darblay position pour que cette
entreprise soit reprise mais dans le
cadre de la filière papetière et
singulièrement avec sa spécificité de
traitement et valorisation des déchets
papiers cartons
l'offre papetière mis sur la table par
les syndicats éviterait non seulement un
démantèlement du site mais permettrait
surtout de conserver un savoir faire
unique en france de saut vers en somme
toute une économie circulaire pour les
syndicats et représentants cadre ce
qu'il manque c'est une réelle prise de
position de la part des pouvoirs publics
mais qu'est ce qui bloque c'est la
volonté de porter un projet papier on
nous a toujours
on en faisait toujours d'ailleurs
cantonné dans dans cette offre papetière
mec est parti ailleurs finalement en ne
portant aucun crédit à d'autres à
d'autres projets sauf que c'est top à
pothières elle est partie elle et elle
est partie sans ses partenaires les
partenaires qui se sont trouvés plantés
ont décidé de revenir avec nous depuis
le 30 juin dernier le démantèlement du
site peut donc arriver à tout moment
de leur côté les salariés et syndicats
comptent plus que jamais sur l'état